Vìa bán hành gỷ định số 1.5 năm, quy định từ ngày 1.5 năm,
các sản thân mạc địa từ, nguyên tạm số sẽ thực hiện khấu chử và lột thế thay hộ,
cá nhân kinh dân trên nền tạm.
Theo đó, sản thân mạc địa từ, nền tạm số phải khấu chử, lột thế thay khoản thử ra chỉ ra tạm,
bây giờ, và thế thu nhập cá nhân chó, cá nhân kinh dân trên sản ngay khi đơn thằng được sắp nhận thành công và người mua chấp nhận thành tỏng.
Người bán sẽ gồm cá nhân cứ chúa ở trong nước bản nước ngoài.
số thuế được sáo định theo kỷ lệ phần chân xanh thu của mỗi sáo dịch được khoản thật.
Thế vr tế từ 1 đến 5 phần chăm,
thế thu nhập cá nhân từ hộ phẩy 5 đến 5 phần chăm tủy lại hình rào dịch và nơi cư chú của người bán.
Chưa hợp đơn vị quần lý sản hón lại không xáo định được sáo dịch là hàng hai dịch vụ,
số thuế khấu chử sẽ tháo mức tỷ lệ khảo nhất.
Vì kê hai thuế này được thực hiện theo thắng,
bối sáo dịch bị vị hoặc trả lại, các sản sẽ phải bụ chử với người bán số thuế đã khấu chử, lột thay.
Cũng theo nghị định hộ, các nhân kinh dân chân xanh phải kế hai,
lột các ngoại thuy khác như thế tư thu đặc biệt bảo vệ môi trường,
tánh viên và cùng có thùng kinh định dành đệ đủ cho xanh.